le pido para empezar una breve síntesis
de su análisis sobre lo que destacaría
de este discurso de borich
Hola muy buenas tardes y gracias por la
invitación como tal dijiste fue un
discurso muy extenso en el fondo una
Cuenta pública muy extensa y es la
primera en que el presidente en el fondo
da un resumen una síntesis de del
trabajo que ha hecho el gobierno cierto
en este caso año y medio en mandato
recordemos que el anterior el gobierno
de Gabriel boric todavía no cumplía un
año de ejercicio del ejecutivo cierto de
la presidencia y en esta por supuesto el
foco estuvo en dar cuenta de los
resultados de la gestión en estos casi
dieciocho meses Yo te diría que hubo un
recorrido amplio por una diversidad de
temas que fueron abordados por el
presidente en su discurso desde temas
que tienen que ver con economía
nacional cierto de economía a nivel
Macro y a nivel micro el paquete
anuncios de paquetes de medidas en el
fondo para aliviar cierto
la carga de la situación económica para
las familias más vulnerables también
varios
énfasis cierto en en el apoyo que que
está otorgando El Ejecutivo a empresas
pequeñas y medianas no recordemos que no
hace mucho discutimos esto se discutió
en el congreso del país cierto el alza
del sueldo mínimo y en torno a esta
discusión Hubo mucho polémica sobre la
carga económica que implicaba para las
pequeñas empresas cierto asumir la
diferencia que se iba a aumentar en el
pago mínimo que recibe una persona
mensualmente por por su trabajo en la
misma línea Sí disculpe para seguir en
estos temas que ha tocado boric hablando
de la cuestión de seguridad por la que
su gobierno ha recibido bastante esa
críticas por una sensación de
inseguridad que aumenta en el país en
qué medida es responsable el gobierno de
borich de este escenario de esta
situación
bueno efectivamente el país enfrenta una
crisis de seguridad que que yo diría que
se corren tres ejes no la seguridad en
cuanto delincuencia común cierto con una
tasa de homicidios que ha aumentado
seguridad también relacionada con eso de
crimen organizado y seguridad derivada
de la situación migratoria desatada
cierto una migración desregulada cierto
que se presentó en los últimos años y
que se ha hecho patente con la Crisis
que hay en la frontera norte con
personas que quieren salir del país a
través de la frontera con con Perú
cierto el presidente fue fue directo en
enfrentar este tema incluso hizo alusión
a críticas que se hacen de que no existe
un apoyo explícito de parte del gobierno
hacia carabineros Pero descartó por
supuesto Esa esa afirmación o ese
supuesto y destacó las medidas que han
implementado desde el ejecutivo para
aumentar un presupuesto de seguridad y
manifestó de la misma forma que
seguridad Era uno de los ejes
principales de preocupación cierto de
este este Ejecutivo en particular y
Michelle le preguntó también en qué modo
el proceso constitucional en Chile está
influyendo al mandato de boric
Bueno es un muy punto muy interesante
porque de hecho el presidente mencionó
en su cuenta
una sensación que tenía cierto de que la
convención constitucional cierto el
organismo que fue constituido para
redactar el anterior proyecto de
Constitución no había interpretado
dijéramos los anhelos de chilenas y
chilenos en el proyecto que se que se
evacue de la misma forma que de cierta
forma la dinámica que se produjo en este
organismo había generado en más
descontento que que adhesión al proyecto
fue yo dijera cauto en en manifestarse
en una posición sobre el actual proyecto
que se inicia de hecho ya con el nuevo
organismo electo El Siete de junio
porque es muy patente y el gobierno de
tener muy claro cierto la crítica que se
hizo El Ejecutivo sobre la el
involucramiento con el anterior proceso
y que finalmente también de cierta forma
el rechazo del proyecto impactó en la
aprobación
del gobierno de la misma forma el se han
interpretado los resultados de la
elección del Consejo Constituyente donde
la derecha en republicanos tiene una
alta presencia también como de cierta
forma una evaluación a la performance
del gobierno de turno Entonces yo creo
que en ese sentido fue bastante cauto
Más allá de manifestar su apoyo cierto y
su su su su su anhelo de que este
proceso sea exitoso